correspondent peter ducey live on the
north lawn good evening peter
good evening brett it has now been six
days
since president biden said anything
about what's going on
at the border members of his
administration have been down there
gathering facts but officials here have
been trying to keep the president's
official events more focused on covet
19.
i learned from running the recovery act
you got to be hands on
that was during a visit to a va facility
giving covet shots
no plans right now for a visit to the
southern border a trip with the
president as many of you know
includes air force one includes an
extensive security includes all of you
of course a small white house delegation
just got back from a tour of border
patrol and hhs facilities for migrants
and the first big takeaway from someone
who was there
we inherited a broken system but despite
a pledge last week to fix a broken
system quickly
the urgency of it cannot be overstated
nobody has filled in
president biden about the border trip
yet we do plan to brief the
president this week on it we have not
done so yet but officials did bring back
first
hand testimonials we did speak
to many of the folks involved including
children the administration recently
defended reopening
an hhs facility for migrant children
arguing more space
was needed for social distancing but now
that's changed and quote
based on cdc guidance office of refugee
resettlement has notified facilities
they may temporarily
reactivate capacity within their full
licensed capability
up to safe occupancy levels cdc also put
out some guidelines
many of you may have seen i believe it
was on thursday or friday
that will allow for increased capacity
at some of these sites the president
made remarks about international women's
day
we need little girls and boys both who
have grown up
dreaming of serving for their country to
know this is what
generals in the united states armed
forces look like this is what vice
presidents of the united states
look like but still no formal solo press
conference
he has done about about 40 q a's
since he took office most of those are
really short
as soon as i get it and that may be the
kind of access the white house has in
mind
after a solo presser they promise will
happen this month
i don't know that you'll see him more
than 40 times a month but i'll have to
tell i'm happy to ask him that question
and somebody else tried again tonight to
ask him a question about the senate
filibuster and whether or not that is
going to affect a voting rights package
in the upper chamber
and the president answered that he would
talk about that
later brett you've been the most
successful getting the news out of those
short questions so
peter thank you